we have an update on a crush of migrants
entering the U.S in El Paso Texas Joan
video shows them lined up at the river
that separates the city from its Mexican
neighbor Juarez some 2400 people sought
to enter this country along that border
along that part of the Border rather on
Sunday alone border officials say they
are just overwhelmed and they need help
Lilia Luciano is in El Paso this morning
with more on this story Lilia good
morning
Gail good morning over the last year and
a half there's been an increasing number
of migrants and Asylum Seekers coming
across the U.S Mexico border in this
city El Paso is now at a Breaking Point
when we landed last night we saw dozens
of Asylum Seekers and migrants camping
out at the airport many had waited along
the Rio Bravo River to get to U.S soil
after Crossing several countries title
42 is a policy that was implemented by
the CDC under the Trump Administration
which allows for quick expulsions as a
way to curb the spread of covid instead
of letting people stay and make their
case for Asylum last month a judge ruled
that title 42 must be lifted on December
21st that is a week from today saying
that the policy was unlawful here in El
Paso shelters are full and local
authorities are asking the bite
Administration and Congress for
emergency funds to manage the crisis as
well as an emergency
Federal shelters so people are not left
to sleep at the airport or at bus stops
or Worse eventually out on the streets
Tony
Lilia thank you very much